avoir un réfrigérateur qui change de
couleur est-ce que ça pourrait vous
botter à la maison c'est ce que nous
propose ici LG au CES c'est-à-dire des
panneaux RGB vous allez pouvoir venir
changer la couleur entre le haut et le
bail entre les moments de la journée je
trouve ça à ce moment parce que le matin
on se met un truc un peu connu pour se
mettre du jaune on se réveille on y va
on a la patate et le soir on est cool on
se met un truc un peu plus je sais pas
rouge tranquille ou un peu de bleu un
peu smoothie on se détend ça c'est
vachement marrant c'est mignon d'assaut
signalée et en plus de ça qui est
relativement marrant ici c'est que vous
avez des haut-parleurs Bluetooth donc
vous pouvez en plus envoyer de la
musique avec le réfrigérateur à la
maison et vous avez également un
assistant vocal voilà alors je sais pas
si ça arrivera chez tout le monde la
référence je vous la donne c'est le mood
up mood pour l'humeur pour l'ambiance
c'est sympa dites-moi ce que vous en
pensez est-ce que vous pourriez est-ce
que vous aimeriez vous avoir un
réfrigérateur qui change de couleur à la
maison tout en sachant que quand même ça
envoie un peu de lumière donc ça va
éclairer votre pièce ça va vraiment
apporter cette humeur dans l'ensemble de
votre cuisine voilà parce que vous en
pensez dans les commentaires